Блок-пости Нацгвардії і патрулі поліції на кожному кроці.
Після початку розведення сил української армії і підконтрольних Росії сепаратистів в районі Золотого
у місті запровадили так званий "жовтий режим безпеки".
Влада боїться провокацій і зриву розведення військ,
яке нарешті вдалось розпочати - після трьох років переговорів,
численних невдалих спроб і попри серйозний спротив частини суспільства.
Посилена присутність силовиків також має заспокоїти місцевих мешканців -
показати їм, що їх не залишили без захисту.
Адже попри те, що з самого Золотого армію не вивели,
побоювання, що до міста можуть зайти сепаратисти, є принаймні у частини мешканців
фронтового містечка.
Навіть у тих із них, хто розведення вітає.
Треба розводити. Але знову ж таки - а раптом ті попруть сюди?
Хлопцям прикро буде - знов ці пагорби займати?
Полягло тут хоч греблю гати.
Так що тут п’ятдесят на п’ятдесят. Але тиша - то добре.
Раніше стріляли кожного дня, а зараз - тиша.
Але побоювання все одно є?
Звісно, є. Я боюсь за себе , я боюсь за свою дитину, я боюсь за свою родину.
Я боюсь, що до нас прийдуть з того боку і почнуть з нами розбиратися.
Це перший крок до миру. Немає ніякої здачі територій. Просто хочеться миру.
Самі розумієте: мир - це запорука здоров’я і достатку.
Є поліція - вона нас охороняє.
Патрулюють вночі.
Я їхав після третьої зміни - перевіряли документи. Я вважаю, це нормально.
Крамничка біля шахти, де ми спілкуємось з місцевими -
одне з небагатьох місць у депресивному шахтарському містечку, де вирує життя.
А власник магазину Віктор Заярний - один із небагатьох мешканців Золотого,
хто відкрито виступає проти відводу військ.
Зі свого села, яке захопили підтримувані Росією сепаратисти, Віктор виїхав ще на початку війни.
Після втечі кілька років жив у власній крамниці.
Я на цій кушетці спав чотири роки, тому що не було де жити.
Тих, хто українець, там зневажають.
Або, якщо ти українець, потрібно жити із закритим ротом.
А я людина, яка не може жити із закритим ротом.
Перед втечею Віктор пережив арешт.
Свій бізнес, що залишився на захопленій сепаратистами території, він втратив.
Тож оптимізму більшості мешканців Золотого щодо розведення підприємець не поділяє.
Вже у нас "шахтарі і колгоспники" Дебальцеве забрали.
Можуть так колишні шахтарі і Золоте-4 раптом забрати.
Володя Путін накаже - і все. Йому все одно ніхто нічого не скаже.
Будуть, правда, потім вмовляти всі, що, мовляв, не треба так робити, дядя Вова.
Одним словом, я тій стороні не довіряю. Не виключено, що можуть сюди увійти.
Ну, або не увійдуть, а диверсії можуть робити.
Все, що ми повернули, ми повернули військовим шляхом.
Дипломатичним шляхом ми тільки втратили.
Вкрай непопулярним кроком розведення є і серед великої частини військових.
Причина та ж сама - недовіра до противника.
І це при тому, що війська відвели від зовсім невеликої ділянки фронту
і лише на один кілометр від лінії розмежування,
а спостерігачі ОБСЄ підтвердили дзеркальність дій сепаратистів.
У приватних бесідах багато хто з бійців зізнається:
бояться, що доведеться знов відвойовувати позиції і території,
за які раніше вже віддавали життя їхні побратими.
Проте під час інтерв’ю на камеру військові менш відверті.
Це домовленості.
Ми їх виконуємо і будемо сподіватись, що та сторона також буде їх дотримуватись.
Ми готові до будь-якого розвитку подій.
Звісно, ми повинні бути готовими і до найгіршого варіанту,
але сподіваємось, що тут буде дотримуватись режим тиші.
Шлях до нових позицій української армії лежить через цей пункт пропуску.
Втім, потрапити туди ми не можемо.
Обмеження "жовтого режиму" поширюються і на журналістів, які акредитовані для роботи на фронті.
Не пропускають нас і до села Катеринівка, частина якого внаслідок розведення сил
стала демілітаризованою або так званою "сірою" зоною.
Із цивільних через КПВВ проїхати можуть лише місцеві
та співробітники гуманітарних місій зі спецдозволом.
Потрапити до Катеринівки можна і нелегально - об'їзними шляхами.
Проте ми вирішуємо не ризикувати акредитацією
і домовляємось про зустріч з місцевою волонтеркою у Золотому,
щоб розпитати її, як живеться у Катеринівці після розведення.
Не чути пострілів тепер. Спокійніше стало. Не видно військових у селі взагалі.
Нас патрулює поліція, охороняє нас. Дуже тихо. Дійсно, кажуть, що ми - сіра зона.
До нас будь-кого не пускають. Ми їздимо за пропискою.
Але волонтерські, гуманітарні організації до нас приїжджають.
А ви довіряєте тій стороні?
Хотілося б довіряти, але трохи страху є. Поживемо - побачимо.
Чим завершиться розведення сил біля Золотого і чи стане воно початком миру на Донбасі
або призведе до остаточної заморозки конфлікту - поки не відомо.
Натомість вже зараз зрозуміло, що шлях до миру буде тривалим і надважким.
Адже ділянка біля Золотого, на якій розвели сили -
це лише один з чотирьохсот кілометрів лінії фронту на сході України.
А ще важче буде досягти компромісу у політичному врегулюванні,
зокрема щодо надання Донбасу особливого статусу,
на якому наполягає Росія і керовані нею сепаратисти.
Адже, згідно з соцопитуваннями, цього не підтримує більша частина українського суспільства.